[Music]  [Music]  you  [Music]  [Music]  our team is the elite of the elite the  heart soul of this very big issue  we protect what no one wants protect  and we go above and beyond and it's  telling you with Sami people you know  refrigerator oh that's a very wash you  put me it's more than this job than just  swimming Victoria leaves in the owner of  the house big fella  truck murder all this started when  police took over  I saw we were lifeguards everything that  you guys talking about sounds like a  really entertaining but far-fetched TV  show I just tell it running all up you  see it  you can be a great watch  night-night  ahem  you turn the canals into the goddamn X  game yeah that's because we were in  lifeguard pursuit  there's no [ __ ] such thing as  lifeguard pursuit even if you were  police what you did would still be  totally illegal okay well I mean it's  good thing we're not police  [Music]  you